und nun liebe zuschauer schnallen sie
sich an
cremen sie sich ein und nun folgen sehr
ungewöhnliche wenn nicht sogar
verstörende bilder wir wollen aber
gemeinsam noch einmal schauen auf diese
bilder hier die älteren unter ihnen die
werden das vielleicht noch keinen eine
jubeln der spd schauen sie mal hier
schauen sie mal jubeln die sozen haben
sie auch gedacht ihr fernseher kaputt
fical spd jubel nach einer wahl über 39
prozent in hamburg cdu 11 über 39 in
hamburg wie haben die sozen das gemacht
sie haben in hamburg zum beispiel viel
mehr wohnungen gebaut als andere städte
also regelrecht versucht reale probleme
zu lösen
das scheinen die wähler zu mögen wer
hätte das gedacht und dann dann waren
die sozen auch noch wahnsinnig stark in
einer ganz bestimmten wählergruppe hier
unten bei den rentnerinnen und rentnern
ist die spd bärenstark hat da auch stark
von der cdu gewonnen und ihr sieg naja
jedenfalls ihre rolle als stärkste
partei ist ganz eindeutig ein sieg bei
rentnerinnen und rentern ja wir nehmen
rücken bestseller der 100 jährige der
aus dem fenster stieg und die spd wählte
best age ich nenne sie immer so weil ich
beim zdf arbeitete best age als retter
die bundespartei hat inzwischen reagiert
und diesen tollen sport gemacht liebe
spd senioren ihr seid das wertvollste
was wir haben übrigens auch das letzte
was wir noch haben
deswegen ist es unheimlich wichtig dass
wir bei der bundestagswahl 2021 noch da
seid wenn ihr versteht was wir meinen
bleibt bis dahin bittet wir brauchen
jede stimme es sind doch nur noch
anderthalb jahre
die schafft er jetzt auch noch hey was
machst du da gehen nicht ins licht nicht
ins licht gehen spd halte durch
wir versuchen
ja
endlich mal wieder ein erfolg für die
alte tante spd
wer sich da nicht mit freud er hat kein
herz liebe zuschauer und hamburg war
natürlich auch eine tolle nachricht für
die neuen vorsitzenden saskia esken und
norbert walter borjans also für die
saskia und den norbert oder und ich
meine mit walter und mit es kriegen wir
das hin
exakt mit es kia und mit walter und wenn
danach noch saskia und norbert mitmachen
wir sind ja schon viel
dann sind das 4
werden die noch aus
das fast schon sensationelle hamburger
comeback der spd will schaut mal live
zum willy brandt haus nach berlin zur
parteizentrale dort steht für uns
albrecht humboldt albrecht welchen
anteil haben denn der wald und die sg am
erfolg von hamburg gute frage herr welke
ich finde die beiden haben wirklich
alles gegeben
also hätten sie aber dann haben die
kollegen aus dem hohen norden gesagt
bleibt man lieber zu hause
das spart ja auch fahrkosten dieser
hamburger genosse ist offensichtlich ein
richtiger fan von escada und waltraud
glauben sie nicht dass die beiden hier
auch positiv wirken könnten wenn sie
hier hören
das ist die große frage das risiko war
uns zu groß deswegen haben wir gesagt
bleib bibel in berlin
sicher ist sicher jeder meter zwischen
euch und uns hilft ganz ehrlich es ist
wirklich deprimierend die neuen
vorsitzenden haben in dieser partei
original gar nichts zu melden
trotzdem hauen sie im minutentakt neue
vorschläge raus was gab es da alles
höhere rentenbeiträge für gutverdiener
höherer spitzensteuersatz höhere steuern
für firmenerben boden wertzuwachs steuer
vermögenssteuer das ende der schwarzen
null die wenn nötig vergesellschaftung
von eigentum außerdem ein spaghetti eis
und eine playstation 5 gut dass mit dem
spaghetti eis habe ich mir ausgedacht
die aber nichts davon wird noch in der
restlichen spd auch nur diskutiert exakt
die erni und der norbert werden komplett
ignoriert von der spd-fraktion von den
ministern als als wären sie luft ich
glaube ja man hat denen nur gesagt sie
wären vorsitzende
alles fake hier wenn die
pressekonferenzen geben da stehen gar
keine echten reporter
und dafür 23 regionalkonferenzen für
vorsitzende die man dann ignoriert
lustig oder
und es kommt ja noch lustiger einer von
beiden hat noch weniger als nichts zu
melden
achten sie mal darauf bei jedem auftritt
denkt novo kurz er darf mal was sagen
und dann mit dem ergebnis dieses
koalition dieses koalitionsgespräche
sehr zufrieden
ja meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
dann will ich gerne anschließen
das was frau kam kaum bauer schon
ausgeführt hat der arme hund kommt da
können wir uns noch mal kurz die
zeitlupe von der sekunde in der er merkt
er essen nie dran da bricht sein kleines
herz ist nicht übertrieben
der ist wirklich nie dran dann folgt ihr
großer auftritt seine rede ein ist
fertig oder meine auch nicht also seine
war fertig aber er durfte sie nicht
vorlesen
es ist doch traurig ich finde frau ich
sage so werden die beiden denn auch
spitzenkandidaten im bundestagswahlkampf
2021 schlecht nein nein nein
2021 kommt ein völlig neues spitzenduo
telegen sympathisch und garantiert ohne
eigene ideen
wir geben hier gerade ihre erste
pressekonferenz darf ich vorstellen
die ist ja und der nova auf
wer sich sofort will ich sofort albrecht
[Applaus]
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt